so there's only one correct path right
prophet sallam he drew uh 70 lines in
the sand
uh and he said that all these sects all
these lines will be in the fire
um and the except one and that one is
the
the majority which is sunni islam we
make
all the decisions but the thing is all
the decisions we make
and we've made and we will make are
already written
in that decree in that goddard of allah
it's not that allah
wrote these things down like computer
programmers
code softwares and then they click run
or execute and the software program runs
that
it's the allah gave us free will but
because he knows us so intimately so
purely because he is our creator he is
the source
he knows us so deeply that he knew what
we were going to do
in every single decision before we even
do it so confidently that he wrote it
down in the color of allah
it's not that he made us do it but he
created us with the free will
so he knew what we're gonna do before we
even do
if we got three doors a b and c
tldr we can choose door a
door b or door c if rami picks door a
allah wrote down rami is going to pick
door a
allah did not make rami pigdor a rami
pick door a
rami gets his good deeds rami sins just
like any other human being rami is in
control but allah
wrote down through how much he knows
rami that rami will pick door
a allah didn't make him do that allah
even wrote down
what would have happened if he didn't
pick dorae what if he picked bador b
dorsey allah wrote everything down but
allah knows him so well that allah wrote
down ramen wrote door a
so long story short guys we do have free
will
but it's not free will in the sense that
oh allah made us do it it's true free
will
but allah still knew what we when we
were gonna do
before we even do these things before we
even think of them
so if let's say i want to learn
what is this five minute mark
romney bro don't don't interrupt me like
this man
i cannot hear you
i still cannot hear you you muted you
fool but um
continuing you still muted bro
i'm not talking this time i said my bad
please continue
okay okay all right so
see man you done you don't make me lose
my training okay purpose purpose so
you're talking about purpose here right
so if you
you want to give yourself purpose you
say okay well you know what
assalamu alaikum ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to the three muslims
actually bro you looking more like it's
the two muslims featuring
white girl on house
yeah you little [ __ ] today aren't you
yes all right so
how are you guys doing today man
beautiful uh tuesday mashallah
yeah alhamdulillah i like that i like
that sweater
i was gonna tell you that that's a nice
sweater yeah i like your tank top bro
i like your beanie thank you thank you
you're welcome man hey y'all know y'all
know this uh
y'all know this romney's getting bigger
yes
you know show them the net gains they're
not gains
[Music]
just just wait wait why you got to flex
any eggs like that
all right i'm just kidding guys rami
does not have an x
no all right guys so this video
this video we're going to be talking
about
the kada of allah yes
free will and transvestites
yeah that was supposed to be a surprise
all right let's get in now you're wrong
bro romney started off bro
right bismillah
free will everybody always has this like
this weird contention that doesn't need
to be there
and actually it goes back to a deep
philosophical argument of predestination
and free will
but there was one philosopher um
what's the name of the brother we were
mentioning before um for us the hobby is
that his name
yeah he was on the jorgen podcast and
you can go watch it's an amazing uh
amazing episode um not to shout out
another podcast t3m is where it's at but
anyways
aside aside from that
um he was explaining how one philosopher
said that
predestination right determinism and
free will are two trains
that move perfectly together
simultaneously because you cannot deny
free will you cannot deny the fact that
we
consciously make choices and we do what
we do but you actually at the same time
you can't deny that things only happen
once they only happen one way and they
happen as a consequence of
other things that are in the past you
can't change right that's what
determinism essentially is
you can't deny either of them and that's
the beauty of islam because islam
combines both of them
we are accountable for our actions but
at the same time
we have the the the destiny and the
qatar of allah
the decree of allah which was dictated
they say fifty thousand years before we
were even created
so or fifty thousand years before even
the creation of heaven's earth
so think about it like this
i'm to talk about the destiny part allah
destines you to be in a situation
let's say allah puts you in a situation
where you end up having to choose door
one
or door two right let's say
there's a sign from allah to choose door
two
you choose to go through door two you
could also choose to disobey go through
door one
one is gonna have good consequences and
one's gonna have bad consequences
let's say you decide to go through door
one right you go through door one
and it's a dark room you spend a few
hours trying to find your way to the
other side right
let's say you go through door two you
listen to allah you go through the door
too it's still your choice allah is not
making you he's just
telling you what's up what you should do
what's what's what's more befitting of
you
according to his plan and then you
choose to go through door two
you go through door two and it's a lot
easier for you right
so let's say that's what happens the
final decision he makes a goal is to go
through door two it is in your destiny
that you will make that decision but
it's still your decision to make
a lot of the time people ask if if god
knows what i'm going to do
how do i have free will and that's
that's
no worries no worries and sometimes they
phrase it like this if god knows what
i'm going to choose to do
if god knows my choices then how do i
have free will
if you admit in the question itself
you're admitting you're the one doing it
you're the one choosing it it's in it's
in the question itself so it's
self-defeating
to say how do i have free will when i
choose what to do
and god knows let me
you know go on bro that's that's
essentially it it's just it's a
self-defeating statement
so the the fact that allah knows does
not remove your ability to choose he
just knows what you're going to choose
that's essentially let me let me break
it down even even simpler
so a lot of people have this this
question that romney posed that
do we have free will or no if allah
knows if god knows if if the most high
knows what we're gonna do
then are we really thinking freely
or are we just in a simulation are we
just doing what he wants us to do
is he making us act or are we doing it
and if we do sins then isn't it how is
it my fault because
god made me do it right for allah
here is the easiest way to think about
it
we have free will i have free will
on who has free will romney got free
will
all right we all got free will but the
thing is
it's not that allah makes us do these
things
but the thing is time is a construct of
our dunya
it is a construct that we as mankind
created
to understand and solve the problems of
arduino
of our world it is not something that
exists
remotely let alone at the same magnitude
in the seven heavens and you know
aside from here so when allah created
this thing called qatar right allah took
a pen
and allah wrote down the qatar allah
wrote down every single thing
that everyone will do okay he wrote down
every single thing that everyone will do
when they're going to do it how they're
going to do it who's going to be there
when they do it
our thoughts allah wrote everything down
before even creating us just like
brother rami said 50 000 years ago
before we were born
then allah creates us with free will
and he creates us and puts us in this
dunya
and we live our life we
make all the decisions but the thing is
all the decisions we make
and we've made and we will make are
already written
in that decree in that goddard of allah
it's not that allah
wrote these things down like computer
programmers
code softwares and then they click run
or execute and the software program runs
that
it's the allah gave us free will but
because he knows us so
intimately so purely because he is our
creator he is the source
he knows us so deeply that he knew what
we were going to do
in every single decision before we even
do it so confidently that he wrote it
down in the color of allah
it's not that he made us do it but he
created us with the free will
so he knew what we're gonna do before we
even do these things
so if we got three doors a b and c
tl dr we can choose door a
door b or door c if rami picks door a
allah wrote down rami is going to pick
door a
allah did not make rami pig or a rami
pick door a
rami gets his good deeds rami sins just
like any other human being rami
is in control but allah wrote down
through how much he knows rami that rami
will pick door a
allah didn't make him do that allah even
wrote down
what would have happened if he didn't
pick dorae what if he picked bador b
dorsey allah wrote everything down but
allah knows him so well that allah wrote
down ramen wrote door a
so long story short guys we do have free
will
but it's not free will in the sense that
oh allah made us do it it's
true free will but allah still knew what
we when
we were gonna do before we even do these
things before we even think of doing
these things
so it's both it's predestination in the
sense that allah wrote down what's gonna
happen not that he made us do it
but it's also free will and i think
that's beautiful marshall it's
essentially like
a video game where
allah is the programmer the creator
of this video game all right now he's
already
basically written out how this video
game is gonna play out
and he he knows everything all the ins
and outs of this video game
are you you being the soul
is now playing this video game
and in this video game you have the
freedom
to experience the video game everything
that
allah has created and programs a video
game but with every
single thing that you do there are
different paths
different choices that you make and at
the end of the day
you are the one playing the video game
you are the one choosing
what path you're gonna take what
decision you're gonna make in this life
in this video game right but even if you
were to pick something else
it's already been programmed into the
video game
so like let's say you're playing this
video game where you have this person in
front of you and you can choose either
to kill them
or to help them right like you kill them
well this is what's gonna happen and if
you help them well
this is what's gonna happen all of that
has already been written
all of that has already been programmed
and that is
that is called in a nutshell it's like
bro even at the end even like
what happens at the end where someone
says was like ah well
like if you play a video game and you
choose so and so things like you're
gonna have this ending
or it's like yeah but if you choose the
other things in the video game
you will also have a different ending
but at the end of the day that ending
was still
programmed into the video game meaning
that
it's all written and allah is omniscient
all knowing
all powerful all everything like he
knows everything so a lot of people want
to say oh well how can we have free will
if
if allah knows everything like if he
knows everything then we have no free
will
or if we have free will then allah
doesn't know everything
because we can do something that uh
technically isn't
in line with the color but bro like it's
it's all in line
yeah 100 subhanallah there's also
another aspect
of sometimes things are going to happen
no matter what you do for example
right let's say you're destined i mean i
don't use a bad example um
i mean it's going to drive the point
home so let's say you're destined to get
sick at 60
right you could spend your whole life
taking care of yourself
or you can spend your whole life
neglecting your body but you still end
up getting
sick at 60 right perhaps this is just an
illness you contract regardless of how
you treat your body right
or let's say you're working at work and
you've been there for 10 years
and you've been the best employee ever
but since
you know due to whatever business
situation they're in they have to let
you go
right you get fired let's say you were a
decent employee you did the bare minimum
but you didn't really go
you didn't excel you still get fired
that same day right
for different work and everything so at
the same time um
we do have free will but sometimes
things are destined to happen that's why
the prosthetic
he said um when a calamity when
something difficult happens to you don't
say if like if i did this if i did that
then this would have happened
rather some this is the destiny that
allah has decided
and allah does as he wills is what it is
um but the real the real good or bad
comes out of how you choose to act in
those situations like let's say
allah allows you to get married and that
marriage is not going to work out ten
years from now
you could be the best husband you can be
you can be the best wife you could be
and get so much reward from allah for
being an amazing spouse
and at the end it still doesn't work out
because of the other person
or you could be a horrible person and
contribute contribute to it not working
out
and it still ends the same day same time
maybe even same reasons
or similar reasons so it's just a matter
of are you being rewarded for those 10
years or with that person are you being
punished for the 10 years you're with
that person it's a matter of how you
choose to treat them
so that's what i mean when i say allah
gives you a situation you choose you
know how to act in that situation
but the qatar allah is firm regardless
so think more of the qatar of allah
as two things one allah knows what
you're gonna do and two allah puts you
in situations that you can't control
and the free will is everything that's
in your control everything you choose to
do
um i think that's that's basically the
best way i can summarize it
[Music]
did you unmute your mic just so you
could say
[Music]
no because i was gonna start talking bro
okay
carry on then mm-hmm i was i was gonna
say that
alhamdulillah very good point both of
you
drive at home even further and i think
we're ready to
talk about sex oh
the transvests i'm gonna put it right up
here
hold up hold up okay before before oh
sex sir
before
listen listen yo before we get into the
next topic
i feel like this is very befitting for
me to say my experience
um with a particular substance
that i took in my jahilia days ajahir
days
all right this is the substance known as
uh
ecstasy i do not condone it i do not
advise anyone takes it this actually
will destroy
your neurotransmitter balance your
neural chemistry
and really mess you up i'm talking about
really mess you up
all right before this example
since it's very befitting i remember
taking this
being at a music festival and guys i
kid you not when i took this thing
i remember being so present and so aware
that i was literally
being guided every movement that i made
everywhere that i walked everywhere that
i looked everything that i said
was already programmed that i was just
literally experiencing just like how
when you play
video game and it has like a cut scene
or like something's happening and like
you're just viewing it you're just
watching it
guys that's exactly what i felt when i
was at this festival i was
moving i was walking in a certain
direction but
i wasn't actually trying to walk in that
direction it's like my body
was being moved by itself going into
this direction
and it's like everything was just
already like
it's weird but everything was already
happening
everything was already gonna happen the
way that it was i was already gonna walk
in this direction
i was already gonna look in this
direction look at this girl
say something over here and i was about
everything was
already destined bro and it was just me
going along for the ride and i say that
because i feel like it's very befitting
you know
one in terms of what we're talking about
but two referring back to the other
video that we're talking about these
things with uh gabriel or brother
gabriel
where it's like in the book it says
not to do these mind-altering substances
is that it's haram to do these things
and the reason for that is because
look at all the side effects that come
with these things
but like yes it might wake you up to
certain things and you might see certain
things and you might have this uh
quote-unquote enlightenment
but it's like dude you you have this
book
that's the word of god and it's
basically
telling you everything that you have
or that you are going to experience if
you are going in that route
like let's say someone doesn't believe
what we're saying they're gonna go and
take
the substance you know what they will
experience
is exactly what's written in the book
which is mind-blowing bro
that's mind-blowing
all right birds and the bees not sex
but sex sex s-e-c-t-s why do you guys
say it likes a giant
sex second just say sectors
scepters nah bro that makes it sound
like some like
business models today we're gonna be
talking about the agricultural sectors
and the effects on climate change
bismillah nah like
nah bro come on all right so uh real
quick
before we talk about sex i want to talk
about something real real real quick
all right this is something that's been
asked about for a while at how now bro
man looks and looks excited
all right so yeah i'm gonna just
you make me just want to take uh take a
carrot brown just put it in your mouth
you know
guys patreon exclusive man you can see
uh you can see us put a carrot
in on his mouth all right link that's a
big
gay bro yeah i mean it's not gabriel
it's mental remember
we talked about it in episode three
actually you talked about in episode
three that it's okay to have
uh mental thoughts as long as you don't
act on them listen
is is the carrot gonna have some ranch
on it
uh it depends bro do you want some ranch
on it
it better have a lot of ranch on it bro
i'm gonna get i'm gonna run me to
rainstorm bro
that carrier better be dripping with a
ranch
oh don't worry man i'm gonna make it
exciting real nice
all right that's that's enough of that
that's enough of that
all right if we're done with that
before we talk about sex and islam i
want to quickly talk about body
modifications
because this is a very growing concern
you see people tatted up
uh you see you see people you know
getting tats and
uh you know they don't regret it they
don't not regret it but
that's not the point the point is in
islam
we cannot get tattoos and people wonder
why can't we get tattoos
people also want okay body modifications
where do we draw the line what if i want
i want to get my i don't know sisters
might want to get the
the you know breasts done i don't want
to say i don't want to say keyword
they might want to get some augmentation
you
is like some caucasian phrase
then what's tito
so hi people people be wondering this
this
is left and right and then they're like
okay what if i want to get
uh my eyes fixed i want to go get
corrective surgery
so long story short bro and ramy will
have more to say on this anil can charm
into when he sees
fitting but in islam
you we don't have a problem with you
having tattoos if you're reverting to
islam
you did not know about tattoos you did
not know about these things in the
sharia law and
you know the natural order that allah
has ordained for us so
if you're coming into islam or you want
to come into islam and you're wondering
damn bro i got a whole ass sleeve and
i'm wearing a nice black tank top and i
got i got a headphone now i'm playing
uh i got a nice sleep you do got a nice
sleep and and they're like okay i wanna
i wanna come in islam but i can't
because
you know every time i go to the masjid
they're gonna look at me for some funny
way here's the thing
he might look at you some funny way but
that's not allah
allah has forgiven you if you truly
repent and you don't get any more
tattoos
and you leave your body clean the way it
is why because allah has already made us
perfect the way we are
we don't need to modify anything to get
anything in this dunya
all right the only validation we need is
from allah we don't need
to feed our ego with tattoos if you're
confused about what i'm saying
go over to angel's main youtube channel
where he has a whole video
on what he wishes he's known before
getting all his taps done and
long story short this is why we cannot
get tattooed any type of body
modification
like getting your tatas done and all
that because
at the end of the day guys and girls it
is you basically saying your body's not
perfect the way it is
and i need to now modify it now what
what is allowed
we allow anything that allows you from a
maladaptive or altered or i guess
abnormal state of physiology anatomy
whatever you want to call it
you are now somewhat somehow some way
shape or form messed up whether your
eyes
can't see more than two feet in front of
you whether your
hair is falling out of your head whether
you know whatever you want to say
if you want to get corrective procedures
and surgeries done that is okay so you
want to go get prk you want to get laser
to fix your eyes
that is okay your hair is falling off
you want to go get a scalp
transplant like a hair transplant from
my understanding
of the scholarly consensus it is allowed
if your intention is just to restore
your hair
if you want to get tattoos on your hair
that's a different story now i'm not the
person that can give you a
the photo on that if you wanna you know
you lost a leg and you wanna get
prosthetics
to you know renew the function of your
leg cool you wanna you know add a third
leg because you feel like you wanna
identify as a
as a three-legged uh giraffe today i
don't know about that i don't think you
could do that you know
you want to go do something else yeah
what if the person has a micro penis
then that's that's the way they're born
bro corrective right
they can correct that no that's not
that's you're not you're normally born
with different varying
sizes bro so that's that's not
correcting it correcting is if you're
born with
a non-functioning penis
and they can give you that function both
of which
makes it easy for other people's micro
penises let's just have a moment of
silence after i'm done saying this
for our condolences to all the brothers
who were born with either a micropenis
or with no function right now real talk
bro real talk not even like laughing
like if someone has that
issue that's that's terrible man
that's true mommy you look like you're
having a hard time holding it in
what like a laugh yeah no i'm holding
back tears
you're only oh you a little too hot to
home right
i got you bro ron uh rami's mom if you
are watching this
your son is still sitting in all other
aspects of life
so you can ignore that one little
shortcoming no pun intended
anyway forget to go on this is the tldr
on body modifications and corrective
surgery
let us talk about sex now take three
so with sex a lot of people are
wondering
and this is to you rami because you you
have a beautiful mashallah wonderful way
of explaining this
we got one thing we got one islam we got
one d we got one um
i'm this i'm that and people don't know
what to follow we've literally had a
brother
i think it was on patreon or ig saying
that he resonates better
with shia i don't think he's either he's
reverted yet but he already knows
before reverting he he resonates better
with shia than sunni
are they correct are they all correct
then you got this thing
ahmadiyya which the ahmedis believe
that there was a man who is a in india i
think
in the 18th century 1869 or
1916 or something he came and that he
was the
mahdi right they literally thought this
man was the mahdi
who is the the chosen one who is going
to come and ordain for us by allah
and then they basically thought he was
that i've heard other people he they
thought that he's a reincarnation of the
prophet
sallam makes no sense and you know they
they have these weird different beliefs
but they basically believe that he is
the mahdi and he came
and now they they think okay cool we
still believe that the prophet saws was
the last
messenger but then they also believed
that this guy
was the messenger when the quran
specifically says we have given you the
prophet
sallam as a seal of all prophets which
makes no sense
so romney i want you to get into that
insha
inshallah it is a it is a big topic
especially for like reverse people
learning about islam
bismillah so the thing is there is
an there is a correct al-qaeda there is
a correct belief system
there is correct beliefs which means
there are incorrect beliefs
and somewhere in between there's a gray
area so let me explain there are some
things in islam you must
believe to be a muslim if you don't
believe these things
you are not considered a muslim by by
sunni opinion
so these things are the six articles of
faith the six pillars of faith so
believe in
one god the angels the prophets and
messengers
the books in revelation destiny which we
spoke about
and um in the day of judgment
if you believe in these these
you believe the quran 100
then you are a muslim by that belief
if you disbelieve in any of those things
at all you are not a muslim
if you disbelieve in even a letter of
the quran say no it shouldn't be there
you are not a muslim so let's take an
example if
in the quran it mentions the night
journey where the prophet he went to
jannah
some people believe he went full body
and soul and some believe he just went
with his soul
and then his soul came back to the body
later you can have either belief you're
still a muslim
so when it comes to the different sects
for example
sufis you have a range of understanding
interpretation you have the far extreme
with like grave worshipping calling on
the dead
they believe that their imam of their
masjid is going to intercede for them
and if their imam of their masjid
doesn't like them then they're going to
hell
that's literally what some of them
believe that's the extreme and you have
other sufis like imam al-ghazali rahim
allah one of the greatest
scholars of islam in islamic history he
was a sufi
he was influenced by sufi beliefs but
not to the extent that he was
taken out of the fold of islam same
thing with shias she as
they their disputes are mainly political
and against certain scholars like they
they won't accept uh sahih bukhari
but then they'll refer to it and they
have their own belief system
or science of hadith and that stuff but
they don't have an authentication
process for example in islam
in in sunni islam we have this
trustworthy person told that trustee
worthy person who told that trustworthy
person who ordered it from the prophet
if they're all trustworthy and they have
good memory and all that it's a huge
science many different um uh uh factors
in it that
scholars take into account then the
hadith will be will remain intact and
the hadith is from the prosecution right
they don't have that they don't know who
came from who if it was made up it was a
fabrication and there are a lot of
fabricated
hadith there were a lot at the time
because of these disputes of sex
and akida and belief so
she has believed that the islamic
leadership
should have been inherited by blood like
kingship is passed down to the sun or
whoever right
but in islam this is not what the
prosthetist encouraged right so in islam
in sunni islam we believe that whoever
is best
fit to be the leader is the leader
whether they're related by bloodline or
not
and you find in islamic history when
the islamic leadership started to be
given as inheritance to a son
that's when all the bad things started
to happen in allah
you hear a lot about muawiyah and and
yazid who are two sahaba and
and what they did and their leaderships
and all this stuff and that's when it
started to go downhill
and uh the the the grandsons of the
prostate center they literally lost
their lives
because of this uh very unfortunate
and to that side i am empathetic hundred
percent with the shiites because i you
know i love them just as much as they do
you know
because they're the you know family of
the prophet salam and we say allah ali
muhammad we say peace be on to muhammad
and the family muhammad so there's no no
problem saying but that aside
it's mainly political disputes or
extremist views
that take you out of the full islam but
this is the thing we're not supposed to
divide
islam into sects we're not supposed to
so why do i say i'm sunni salifi why
would i say that salafi and sunni are
basically interchangeable but why do i
say that
the reason we have to say i'm sunni i'm
salafi
is because we live in a day where there
are different sects and you must
elaborate on what you mean
because if someone says i'm muslim
you're like oh this is my brother in
islam it's my sister instead they're
muslim like me
not to cut you off but really important
point this is for people that are always
wondering
where he's going with this this is to
answer the question that we always get
left and right and center
what if there are no sex if there's only
one true way of islam which is sunni
why is there even the sect of sunni and
that's what he's
answering right now yeah yeah so there's
only one correct path
right prophet he drew 70 lines in the
sand
uh and he said that all these sects all
these lines will be in the fire
um and the except one and that one is
the
majority which is sunni islam but that
aside thank you for
clarifying that just but what i was
saying
if i can remember what i was saying was
oh yeah the reason we have to say we're
sunni salafi
is because there is one correct way
right and we have to elaborate on what
we mean if
i meet someone they say i'm a muslim i
say oh cool i'm a muslim but then they
say they're ahmadi
ahmadis are not muslim because as
brother if i had mentioned
allah says in the quran that the prophet
saw is
one means the seal and one means the
last and they're both valid
recitations of the quran so meaning he's
the last of the prophets and then they
believe in a prophet after him
not messenger prophet nabi
right so this is why they fall out of
the
the um the fold of islam because they're
going against the quran directly
like i said if you disobey just one
verse or one if you disagree with one
letter
one letter you're not a muslim imagine
disagreeing with this entire ayah
that there would be no prophet muhammad
because he's the last one
so this is why it's important because
when i say sunni
salafi i'm basically saying i'm a muslim
who follows the quran and the sunnah
i accept the mainstream scholars i
accept imam
ghazali iman bukhari imam shafi hanafi
hanbali maliki mathebs so on and so
forth that's what i'm saying
but at the end of the day if somebody
believes in the six
articles of faith and they believe in
the quran 100
and they don't have some insane belief
that takes them out of the fold of islam
like oh god made a mistake choosing the
prophet muhammad saw
then they are still muslim but if they
have some weird belief they don't
believe in a part of the quran
or they they don't believe in one of the
six articles of faith then they are not
a muslim at the end of the day yo real
quick what's up
you're basically saying if somebody is
from another sect of islam
they could go to heaven insha allah like
if allah wills
yeah potentially if they believe in the
six pillars of iman and the fathers of
islam of the demon then i'm wondering
why the prophet
in your opinion yeah made that
distinction about
drawing in the sand and all of these
ones aside from the majority will go
to yeah that's that's a good question
because
it you could argue that the the people
with the correct view
um could be a shia person right
because if if we limit it to like the
bare minimum the quran
uh the six pillars of iman and you don't
have any crazy sins
then maybe he's a part of the jamaa
right but
yeah maybe and this is just my
understanding could be awful so we
should always go to the scholars about
things like this
but um at the same time we look at
things like ahmadis right
or you look like people who were who um
engage in in like
grave worshiping or intercession or
turning to the imams for intercession
all these different beliefs at the you
know uh even if they claim to be
sufi or sadafi or shia or this or that
the other
and perhaps it's it's limited to the
people
who no they've been because there have
been many people in the past who have
been debated against
argued against it's been made clear but
they won't go away because they're
treating their own sect as if it is the
religion
they won't accept any other proofs
evidence and so on and so forth that's
why people
deny sahel or they say no that's just a
metaphor and
so on and so forth so at the end of the
day even a jew or a christian or a
non-muslim can make it into heaven
if they weren't given the message of
islam because allah says we don't punish
anyone who wasn't given the message
so let's say someone grew up on a weird
understanding of islam they didn't know
any better
allah adam it could be possible for that
person um
but at the end of the day it's very you
know it's a very
maybe this may be that kind of thing and
everybody needs to do their research
and go back to the quran and sunnah to
make sure that you know they're on the
right path because it's obligatory for
every muslim
to seek knowledge it's not enough for
you to say oh i was just ignorant
because if imagine allah asked you on
the day of judgment why did you do this
this that
you weren't practicing islam correctly
and he said well i i just didn't know
and he's like
why didn't you go make sure you learned
now what are you gonna say
nothing because it's obligatory for
every muslim to go seek out knowledge
so if allah asked you on the day of
judgment why didn't you seek out
knowledge
uh but i i i wanted uh no it's too late
at that point
late buddy yeah
yo and i just want to throw in here like
i think that's all amazing and this is
coming from
a reverse perspective so please bear
with me
and understand that this is uh things
that i've gathered along the way
and then my own kind of understanding
kind of playing in here
but i watched this video where musti
mink
uh he was asked this question about like
the sectors and stuff like that he
he basically studies like each sector
has his pros and cons
and he's like the moment that you say
that you are uh
so-and-so well now you have to accept
the bad along with the good
and he's like at the end of the day like
you're a muslim
and you have to follow the things that
rami said
like as long as you follow all of these
things like you are a muslim
and then everything else is like
you you take from it what you will so
it's like the sufis
they are saying certain things and it's
like well when you get to the extreme
part of the sufism
you're like whoa buddy like things took
a sharp left turn here
but if if you actually look into it and
research and study
you will find that there's a lot of
things in sufism that
you can take from it and you can bring
it into your
practice into your uh your dean and you
can see that it will
just further help you even more
you know and again this is from my
experiences
from my perspective you know i'm not
saying this is 100
the truth but it's like dude if that
if that's the case and i think he said
in the video too where it's like let's
say you had an
instructor who's a homosexual instructor
he's teaching you physics
like all right you take from him what
you will meaning that like if he's
talking about his personal life and all
that
you don't have to accept that and take
that on to be
your own beliefs and your own way of
living
you know you're just taking what he's
telling you about physics
and then you are just continuing on it's
like
you're still giving him respect but
you're taking from it what you will and
that's how it should be
where it's like a muslim is exactly what
rami said
and then everything else should only be
little things that you might take
as you will if it aids you in
your course and your path and your
practice
man and you don't go to the point where
you're like nah f this guy because you
know he's gay
i don't want to learn physics from him
or he's wrong about physics not it's
like
see the good in everyone he's right you
don't have to like take
everything from him and adopt his ways
you know what i mean but you could
definitely
take the physics and not take the
biology
from him if you know what i'm saying all
right so with that being said
i think we should talk about one more
thing and
you guys you guys already know if you
made it this far not in this episode but
in
t3m as a channel then you already know
we are nothing if we don't keep it
unfiltered unscripted and raw
so i had this thought come into my head
so i say we entertain it
the thought was as rami is explaining
she has believed that you know about
this inheritance and all that
and you know we believe and no we're not
going to give it to whoever so we're
going to
give it to who the majority votes into
you know it's like a kind of like
who everyone wants and i i agree with
that i believe in that
but the weird thing is as you're saying
this bro
i just had this moment of deja vu y'all
know what deja vu is right
where it's like yo i've we've already
recorded this podcast
like i'm literally getting flashes of
yesterday where you are teaching us
about that and we never you never did
and then it gets me wondering about
this whole thing about deja vu and
what it is what it's not because just
like dreams
they're they feel so real but unlike
dreams they're when we're in a state of
consciousness and we're awake
so what is up with all this i think deja
vu
is directly linked to the color of allah
and it's like how we were talking about
how it's all programmed it's already
written
everything is already set out we have
the free will we can make the decisions
and stuff like that
but sometimes just sometimes
we have that slight glimpse and that
slight awareness where it's like
oh oh like i see it kind of like when i
took that substance and i could see
what was going on well like without the
substance we had those slight moments
where we realized like oh
like i i i've seen this i this has
already happened or something like that
deja vu
no bro it was already going to happen
it was already going to happen you're
just becoming aware of the fact that
like
hey that blows my mind bro this is this
is more than what you think it is
yeah blows online or i want to propose
like a
random possible neurological
uh theory what if because you when
you're taking in certain information
right and i have like no extreme idea of
what i'm talking about this is very
basic right
um and i'm not professional by any means
right but you're studying biology so
uh it may or may not may or may not tie
in
so let's say when you're taking
information right this
you're creating new like neurological
patterns right in your brain right
you're creating new patterns in your
brain to be able to retain the
information right
yeah what if your brain gets confused
as if it's recalling a new memory as
it's putting in new information so
that's why you you're one observing
what's happening
but two you feel like it's happened
before you feel like you're recalling a
memory
maybe it could be it could be but think
about it like sometimes you
experience something that of which
you've never experienced before
you have nothing that can be a
recollection or a recall
or a past experience or a past memory
yeah but less
information yeah what i'm talking about
when we perceive
new stimuli or reoccurring stimuli our
memory
i believe is the retrieval and encoding
and storage
process in our in our brain it's uh by
your hippocampus
and it takes our memories in our current
experiences and it attributes it to a
past memory
or a new memory and i think what
romney's getting to is
that pathway of where it's going gets
kind of shifted
and kind of blurry and you get confused
as is if it's a new memory or it's
already a past
recurring memory yeah i think that's
what you're trying to say
yeah by the way bro you are a
professional don't don't get it twisted
don't don't tell us you're not
professional
you are giving professional advice it's
unlicensed though
it's just like the hot stones say but
you are professional nonetheless
i just want to make sure i'm not a
neurologist i don't want anyone going
around saying like
oh but this guy on the podcast said that
you know when you get deja vu it's like
this
i mean bro here's the thing that guy we
used to watch growing up bill nye the
science guy
yeah isn't he like he has no degrees or
anything
i don't i don't know if this is true
enough i'm looking for himself yeah look
at that because someone told me that
this man
we look at him as like the gold standard
he knows about everything but
if it's licensing he's not a doctor or
anything but who check
bill nye the science guy
he has he has a he has in mechanical
engineering
he's not the only one with a bs in
mechanical engineering my uh
my family doctor is an engineer he did
his undergrad in engineering
because those of y'all don't know in
canada we got to do undergrad then we
got to go to
grad school yeah and med so in undergrad
he did in engineering which is crazy
hard compared to anything else
and with that gpa this man went into met
so alhamdulillah
yoga
listen listen to tie everything in
to what rami said and what you he
basically elaborated on what he was
saying about the retrieval
and the new information that's coming in
that's being processed
this can still
be linked with the color of allah with
the experience that i gave
because the experience that i gave could
be
interpreted as a
what's it called a um a glitch
a glitch in the matrix a glitch in the
dunya
where you see it for what it is or you
see something more than what you are
perceiving
uh by ordinary means so like in and of
itself
okay is it um is it
information that's just being processed
like not
accordingly yeah but even if it is being
processed uh
not accordingly and causing the deja vu
to occur
it's still creating a lapse in the dunya
still creating
a lapse to where you feel like oh wow
i've already experienced this so like
something's different here
do you get what i'm saying yeah like why
can't it be both
exactly exactly mean that like they're
both
amazing points yeah but they also both
tie in with each other yeah
yeah masha'allah masha'allah
you all got anything to say before we
wrap it up and now we're talking about
the transvestites right
until we throw that into the next
episode bro i patreon exclusives
all right so uh 1.2 what were you going
to say
fired before no i'll see if you are done
we can wrap it up then
all right yeah i'm done we don't we
don't intend to contradict any
you know so now i did in the quran
nothing i got this from us
rephrase that yeah um and we're not
going to edit this just for y'all
because
anything we say incorrect everything bad
is from us into shaytan
and allah and the prophet sallam are
protected from it
um rami man real quick before you
end it off for us yeah what made you
choose
engineering i've always had a creative
mind i've always
been creating things making things like
bro when i was a kid
when i was a kid i used to make paper
guns that would shoot
i just make paperwork yeah
whether it was like a blow dark blow
dart kind of thing it's a gun but like
you kind of like
i mean i don't want it to get stuck in
there but yeah blow dart kind of thing
i'm not saying you blow it but you know
what i mean and it shoots the bullet
pawns
no it's not bro yeah
yeah exactly but just it's built like a
gun or like a an elastic thing you know
i was always making guns and like and
all this stuff it's causing modern
warfare too so don't don't uh
don't bring that up to me again but
it'll be like this guys
yeah but you know that youtuber the
glorious quran
yeah he makes the memes he's gonna wait
for you when you took your hands and you
you wrapped it around when you're using
the blow dart you're gonna make some
type of meme out of that bro
go ahead go away but yeah i've always
been
you know i've always been creative and i
want to use that creative capacity
and i've always been uh you know in
light not enlightened man uh inspired
you know uh by the
the sciences and all that so thank you
what you're saying is
fathers will easily trust you with their
daughters
more times than they would i mean yeah
i'm i'm saying
there are definitely four fathers that
will give me their daughters hen and
married inshallah
only four there could be a hundred
fathers
that happily give you the daughter's
hands
yeah in marriage but not at the same
time because you can only before at the
same time
and even then it's not at the same time
at the same time mm-hmm
in shock there's levels to this about
inshallah yo
sophia what made you want to be
a uh a bone doctor
what made me want to be a bone doctor
what's the terminology of it
osteopath osteopath yeah so
that's my specialization what i really
wanted to why i wanted to do that here's
the thing
i love being a doctor like medicine
and i love bones
what i felt like nah man i just had to
give ibn murad a clip
for his funniest moments okay okay yeah
fair enough the things i do for this man
but uh
anyway shout out to evan man uh for
always holding it down
could you could you imagine the real og
yeah why i really like like um just
osteopathic medicine
and and just you know the whole human
body as a whole is because
it preaches about the the body being a
unit all right
that's the first osteopathic medical
philosophy that we have to say
um and i think day one and the reason
being is
the body is a unit bro it's not like
there's no other way to say it the truth
is in itself
um i had this knee problem and angel was
telling me about
how uh you know you have a knee problem
but the problem is not from the knee
the somatic manifestation is the knee or
you know the symptom is the knee but the
actual
cause or the what what is causing that
the the point of of the room it's
not the knee it's somewhere else that
reminds me in school in classes we're
learning how like
it's just it's a whole system bro like
if you have a problem in one area it
might solve the other area
if you have a true problem with let's
say inflammation it might manifest
itself
in let's say dry eyes or whatever you
want to say or as
whatever and the thing with modern you
know
allopathic medicine which is just like
modern medicine
right it has to do with fixing the
symptom
oh you have asthma let's give you an
inhaler
you have knee pain let's give you
anti-inflammatory medications
but the thing with osteopathic medicine
which is
not like allopathic medicine right
because like in the states they have
like md schools in d.o schools
i'm talking about the latter obviously
were heavily
proponents of the idea of letting the
body naturally heal itself but getting
to the root of the issue
not attacking the symptom so unlike
the the you know physician the
traditional
modern medicine who which will tell you
okay you have
a problem with let's say your eyes let's
give you these drugs for your eyes so
let's give you
this medication to take for your eyes or
let's stop the uh let's
give you a drug that lets you you know
produce more tears
instead of that we're gonna solve the
actual underlying issue
whether it be you know inflammation or
whether it be something in your
in your cranial nerves and we will get
to the root of the issue
and i feel like this is a much healthier
way yeah we do surgery we learn about
you know surgical training and all that
but it's like a last
worst case scenario type thing and we
let the body naturally heal stuff
whereas
you know allopathic medicine is all
about okay drugs
surgery manual things pharmaceuticals
a lot of money in that here's the thing
if everyone
studied osteopathic medicine and became
a medical practitioner
in this means is there is there a lot of
money in that
no because we would have one or two or
three sessions with you
um you come for treatment we fix you and
then you never have to see us again
that's it but if that's true i'm an
allopathic
medical practitioner and i can prescribe
you a drug
that you now have to take for life like
high blood pressure medication
there is what 12 a week times
52 weeks in a year times your whole life
that's
thousands if not tens of thousands
and when you take these drugs i don't
want to get too much into conspiracy
but you then become dependent on the
drug
you then need the drug so without the
drug
your symptoms are now going to be worse
than when you were before the drug
this has to do with antidepressants
psychiatric uh
you know anxiolytics any type of
physical or mental
drug that you take pharmaceutical
prescription it's going to give you
these weird symptoms bro and
you're then going to need it and that's
going to lead you into a further window
of more
disorders and diseases right so all in
all bro
i don't know anyone that just has high
blood pressure medication they went for
high blood pressure
then they got put on cholesterol
medication then they got put on
statin inhibitors and you name it bro so
it's just a downward slippery slope
an insurance big pharma bro there's no
money in it
if they can't charge you right i'm not
saying there's a cure to cancer guys but
i'm saying if there was a cure to cancer
would they really make it mainstream
to the general public so you can come in
for one thing and be done or would they
put you on chemo and radiation and drugs
for years
to get more money at you and these
insurance companies you tell me
but long story short bro it always
fascinated me as a kid
but i'm a personal trainer too um not as
a career
but this is something i do passionately
and
i love letting the body that allah gave
us
naturally function and thrive i don't
like
these external interventions and
drugs and all this all right i know
romney might disagree
i'm just playing um you know because
romney looks like he's he's into
pharmaceuticals bro he
he looks he's on what seven or eight
different medications what do you want
nine nine damn bro so uh
what do you think the viagra is your
favorite yeah for sure 100 percent
just being one of the marshallers guys
just
a quick disclaimer romney does not take
viagra
to perform the natural obligation not
anymore he takes the viagra strictly for
pre-workout
means because it gives him the best pump
yeah
yeah as you can see in my neck you know
oh you're on the cialis right now yeah
yeah
bro this is not even patreon we're
giving this out man come on
with that being said ryan i want you to
get out all right jessica if you guys
made it this
this far into the podcast comment neca
gains
in the comment section below hey guys
may allah bless you all i hope this has
been beneficial
with that being said we'll catch you
guys in the next one insha'allah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]